Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfshark más sobre esto En un momento
paren la rotativas ha muerto Silvio
berlusconi no hace falta que es verdad
[Música]
da igual desde donde estáis viendo este
vídeo todos sabéis de quién hablo y eso
en sí mismo es algo sorprendente muchos
lo han querido comparar con Donald Trump
pero ya quisiera el pobre de Donald
Trump parecerse ligeramente a verlos con
y podríamos decir que verlos con y
realmente empezó de la nada y conquistó
el poder absoluto como casi nadie lo ha
hecho en la historia no solo conquistó
el poder político en Italia sino que
también aglutinó el poder empresarial y
el mediático Y si el poder corrompe el
poder absoluto corrompea absolutamente
Así que la vida de berlusconi tiene
muchas sombras pero también muchas luces
de entrada hay algo que le tenemos que
reconocer a este hombre y es que
francamente es envidiable su energía
pensando bien pero luzcanía muerto este
12 de junio con 86 años vamos que era un
señor mayor Pues bien un año antes de su
muerte el año pasado salió en tiktok con
este vídeo
canal y un fichaje y tiktok no vamos a
entrar en el mensaje del vídeo lo que
quiero Resaltar es que ese señor que
veis tenía 85 años en el momento en el
que se lo grababa y ese vídeo es un
anuncio en el que se estaba presentando
de nuevo a unas elecciones en las que
tenía posibilidades reales de ganar no
sé vosotros pero Ojalá llegue yo a los
85 años con esa energía dicho esto vamos
a alabar a ver los que en este vídeo
pues Por supuesto que no
hablar de berlusconi es hablar de
corrupción leyes hechas a medida y un
legado político cuanto menos mediocre
podríamos decir que buena parte de los
problemas de los que sufre Italia que no
son pocos son culpa suya Supongo que la
mayoría de obituarios que leáis por ahí
también mencionarán los muchísimos
escándalos sexuales de berlusconi y sus
bunga bunga partys nosotros vamos a
pasar por alto todo esto porque nos
queremos centrar en dos cosas el perfil
político y el perfil empresarial de este
hombre y creedme solo con eso tendríamos
por hacer una película de hecho ya hay
un biopic de berlusconi y es toda una
Obra maestra se llama loro de Paolo
sorrentino muy recomendable pero para
bien o para mal berlusconia ha definido
lo que es Italia hoy en día no solo eso
también supuso una auténtica Revolución
en los medios de comunicación de Europa
de hecho Si ves Este vídeo desde España
y este ha sido en los años 80 tengo que
decirte que ver luz Connie ha marcado tu
infancia sin que te hayas dado cuenta
dicho esto por qué todo el mundo conoce
a borusconi cuál es su legado político
Por qué decimos que ha sido semejante
revolucionario en el mundo empresarial y
mediático hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes Te has parado lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar lo
primero de todo y lo más importante es
la seguridad en la red con surfshark tu
actividad online está protegida como si
fuera pornox cifrada y a salvo de ojos
curiosos que quieran meter mano en tus
datos además con cleanweb te despides de
los anuncios y del malware y tus emails
Pues con sus arcaled te enteras al
instante si alguien ha intentado filtrar
tu información pero un momento porque
hay más surfshark es la primera VPN
comercial que tiene servidores en más de
un centenar de países Imagínate es como
tener un pasaporte global a un solo clic
puedes acceder a cualquier contenido
bloqueado por ubicación Y si te preocupa
tener que elegir en Qué dispositivo
usarlo tranquilo porque con la misma
cuenta puedes proteger todos tus
dispositivos ya sea tu móvil tu tablet
la tele o el ordenador y un pequeño
secreto entre tú y yo puedes compartir
la cuenta con tus colegas así entre
todos cada uno paga unos céntimos al mes
y ya está además por ser parte de la
comunidad visualpolitik podrás disfrutar
de tres meses extra totalmente gratis
utilizando el código politik terminado
en K y dicho esto continuamos con
nuestro video de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la primera diferencia entre verlos con y
Donald Trump es el nacimiento y es que
mientras que Trump nació en una familia
que ya era inmensamente rica berlus
Connie nació en una familia de clase
media en Milán padres normales educación
normal y vida normal sin embargo
berlusco ni Tenía algo muy especial le
fascinaba el espectáculo y era el mejor
comercial que te puedes encontrar vamos
que sería capaz de venderme un peine
hasta mí De hecho los inicios de
berlusconi fueron como cantante habéis
oído bien empezó su carrera como un
cruner que amenizaba fiestas en cruceros
y cosas por el estilo por supuesto Aquí
también comenzó su fama como
rompecorazones pero como hemos dicho no
vamos a centrarnos en la vida sexual de
nadie porque somos un canal serio El
caso es que amenizando las noches
milanesas verlos con e hizo los
contactos para comenzar su primer gran
proyecto empresarial Milano dué una mega
promoción de 4.000 viviendas que fue
todo un éxito económico pero no se
equivoquéis lo que a verlos con él le
interesaba realmente no era el mercado
inmobiliario sino los medios de
comunicación de hecho la tesis doctoral
de berlusconi Versa precisamente sobre
el negocio de la publicidad en los
medios de comunicación por cierto tesis
con la que obtuvo una suma Kung laude
vamos que de tonto no tenía un pelo de
hecho en estos primeros años de su
carrera tenemos que reconocerle una cosa
fue todo un visionario Por qué pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
El padrino de la televisión privada
si veis este vídeo desde los Estados
Unidos os vais a sorprender pero hubo un
momento donde las televisiones privadas
estaban prohibidas en buena parte de
Europa y ojo no hablamos de la Europa
del este comunista en los años 70 la
televisión en Italia y en otros países
como España era un monopolio público es
decir que si tú encías la tele solo
tenías los canales de la RAE es decir la
corporación de televisión pública
italiana para que os hagáis una idea en
1973 el gobierno italiano emitió un
decreto que prohibía cualquier intento
de montar una tele privada De hecho no
solo tenían el monopolio de la
televisión sino también el de la
publicidad en la televisión y creedme
eso era un negocio muy pero que muy
lucrativo y verlos con era consciente de
todo esto y por eso Su objetivo era
acabar con este monopolio para tener su
propia televisión nacional y la pregunta
es cómo lo hizo Pues atentos porque esta
es una historia digna de un vídeo de
visualpolitik la primera pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es por qué la
televisión era un monopolio público pues
por el espectro radioeléctrico
por aquella época no existía la
televisión digital ni mucho menos
internet la televisión se emitía por
radiofrecuencia y el espectro
radioeléctrico es limitado dicho de otra
forma No hay frecuencias infinitas para
todo aquel que quiera emitir por
televisión sin embargo por esos años
surgió una nueva tecnología para emitir
televisión
la televisión por cable ofrecía espacio
suficiente para emitir múltiples canales
de televisión el problema no todas las
casas en Italia estaban preparadas para
recibirla salvo las viviendas de Milano
dué
[Música]
Exacto pero se encargó de que su
promoción de 4000 viviendas tuviera
televisión por cable después de una
larga batalla legal el tribunal
constitucional italiano permitió la
creación de televisiones privadas que
emitieran por cables siempre y cuando lo
hicieran únicamente a nivel local Pues
bien verlos con y tenía 4.000 hogares
que podían convertirse en espectadores
de su propia televisión y así es como
nació tele Milano una televisión que ni
siquiera era local era una televisión de
barrio Por supuesto que telemilano no
era la única televisión local que metía
por cable pero sí era una de las más
populares porque tenía 4.000
espectadores cautivos Pero esperad
porque esto es solo el principio dos
años más tarde en 1976 el constitucional
italiano volvió a pronunciarse sobre el
tema de las teles esta vez permitieron
que las televisiones privadas pudieran
emitir por radiofrecuencia siempre y
cuando fueran simplemente locales es
decir que podías tener una televisión en
Milán en Torino o en Roma pero no una
tele que emitiera a nivel nacional y qué
creéis que hizo verlo en ese momento
pues alguno de Silvio se dedicó a
comprar casi todas las teles locales de
todas las regiones de Italia en pocos
años se hizo con Roma televisión vídeo
benettorino básicamente consiguió
hacerse con todas las teles Privadas del
país o prácticamente todas siguiente
paso unirlas en el primer grupo de
comunicación de Italia y así es como en
1961 todas estas televisiones locales
cambiaron sus logos por el de Canal 5
y así es como ver los Connie consiguió
lo que parecía imposible acabar con un
monopolio público ahora podía competir
cara a cara con el Imperio de la raid
gracias a tener una red Nacional de
televisiones que en el 5 podía fichar a
los comunicadores más de la televisión
pública Así es por ejemplo como el
famoso Mike whenger se fue de la
corporación pública la nueva y flamante
televisión privada la estrategia no
podía ser más agresiva pero los Connie
quería comerse el mercado y para eso no
reparen gastos compró las series más
populares de Estados Unidos e incluso
introdujo el anime japonés en los
hogares italianos para que os hagáis una
idea tan solo entre 1980 y 1981 Canal 5
pasó de facturar 13.000 millones de Lira
a más de 75.000 para el año 1987 la tele
de verlos con ella tenía el 48% de la
cuota de pantalla de todo el país
[Música]
por si no estáis pasmados todavía
recordad que tan solo 15 años antes las
televisiones privadas en Italia ni
siquiera estaban permitidas por la ley y
esto es un mérito que le tenemos que
reconocer a berlusconi pero si pensabais
que su carrera empresarial se queda aquí
estáis muy equivocados Porque después de
conquistar Italia Silvio se lanzó a
conquistar Europa y vaya si lo hizo Así
es como nació el grupo mediaset que
todavía hoy es uno de los grupos de
comunicación más grandes de Europa
básicamente este nombre se dedicó a
comprar acciones de muchas de las
televisiones privadas que empezaban a
surgir en otros países de su entorno y
aquí es donde llegamos a España porque
hasta el año 1989 la televisión privada
también estaba prohibida en este país
pero en los años 90 el gobierno acabó
con el monopolio público Y ahí estaba el
bueno de Silvio También conocido como
ilcaba cleri listo para hacerse con
teletín de nuevo si sois españoles ya
habéis vivido en los años 90 no hace
falta que se explique lo que supuso
telecinco en los medios de comunicación
habrá quien diga que este fue el inicio
de la telebasura y el sensacionalismo
Pero nadie puede negar que fue un antes
y un después en el modo en el que
entendíamos este medio y aquí es donde
llegamos a la cara B del carrerón
empresarial de berlusconi la deuda no
construye semejante imperio mediático en
poco más de 10 años sin pedir dinero
prestado a medio mundo para el año 1994
Finn best que es el brazo financiero del
imperio de Silvio era la segunda empresa
más endeudada de toda Italia y en ese
momento qué creéis que hizo Cuál es el
siguiente paso que das cuando te has
convertido en el El señor de los medios
de Europa pues recoger tus cosas y
marcharte de la empresa habéis oído bien
en 1994 berlusconi dejó todos sus
puestos directivos Eso sí mantuvo todas
las acciones de su imperio y quedaos con
este dato porque va a ser muy importante
para la siguiente parte de la historia
porque a dónde se fue ver los Connie
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la conquista política
la política italiana es una auténtica
locura da igual cuando escuches esto
porque vale para cualquier época de la
historia en este país los primeros
ministros duran de media 2,5 años y si
estudias la política italiana Vais a
encontrar de todo conspiraciones
llevadas a cabo por logias secretas
terrorismo de estado y por supuesto
mafias de todos los colores hasta ese
momento solamente había una constante la
democracia cristiana hablamos de un
partido de Centro derecha que dominó el
país durante casi toda la Guerra Fría
sin embargo en 1994 la democracia
cristiana se disolvió por una espiral de
escándalos de corrupción dignos de
República bananera la derecha estaba
huérfana y la izquierda no terminaba de
convencer a los votantes pero allí donde
hay gente dispuesta a comprar hay
alguien dispuesto a vender y quién sabe
vender mejor que nadie Exacto Silvio
berlusconi Durante los años 80 había
apoyado públicamente al partido
socialista pero ahora sabía que si
quería ganar las elecciones tenía que
cambiar de bando y así es como creó su
propio partido de Centro derecha Aunque
bueno podría es decir realmente que era
un partido sin ideología básicamente el
proceso fue el siguiente que les gusta a
los italianos más que la pizza y las
mujeres el fútbol y qué gritan Los
italianos cuando apoyan a su selección
nacional Forza Italia fenomenal pues ya
tenemos el nombre del partido ideología
Pues mira estamos a favor de lo bueno y
en contra de lo malo quién no va a votar
un partido así y así es como en 1994 año
del mundial de fútbol berlus Connie creó
Force a Italia
[Música]
creo que no hace falta que os diga que
ese mismo año berlus con y ganó las
elecciones Y diréis por qué pues tres
razones la primera tenía el control de
la televisión más grande del país la
segunda el resto de partidos estaban
matándose en disputas internas y tercera
estamos hablando de una de las
personalidades más carismáticas que se
han conocido en el mundo y así es como
empezó la carrera política más
impresionante de la historia de Italia
ojo Eso no significa que Silvio haya
ganado siempre las elecciones recordad
que la política italiana es un caos
incluso Para Silvio berlusconi ha sido
Primer Ministro en periodos
interrumpidos podemos decir que ha sido
el Primer Ministro con más poder Por qué
Pues porque no solo controlaba la
política sino también los medios para
que os hagáis una idea según
estimaciones de The economist en 2001
llegó a controlar el 91% de la cuota de
pantalla de las televisiones italianas
pensando así era el dueño del Canal 5 y
a la vez dominaba la televisión pública
conclusión el hombre que acabó con el
monopolio de la televisión en los 80
terminó construyendo otro monopolio
[Música]
y aquí es donde llegamos a la parte más
oscura de su vida porque si el poder
corrompe el poder absoluto corrompe
absolutamente y verlos coni convirtió el
parlamento en su patio trasero simple
llanamente aprobó leyes hechas a su
medida por ejemplo en 2004 Italia aprobó
una ley para dar ayudas para la compra
de decodificadores de televisión digital
y quien tenía la principal empresa que
vendía estos aparatos Exacto la familia
berlusconi y este es solo un ejemplo más
de una larguísima lista amnistía
Fiscales regulaciones financieras
podemos decir que Silvio cambio Italia
para hacerla a la medida de sus
intereses
pero ahora vamos a lo más importante de
todo la foto general qué saldo político
deja ver los cony es decir aparte de la
corrupción y el tráfico de influencias
ha sido bueno para los italianos Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el poder por el poder
la economía italiana está incluso peor
que su clase política y también da igual
Cuando leas esto en realidad Italia Tuvo
una época muy buena en los años 80 es
decir cuando berlusconi construyó su
imperio empresarial el país estaba On
Fire a principios de los años 90 Los
italianos eran más ricos incluso que los
británicos y Estaban cerca de alcanzar a
los alemanes ahora sin embargo Italia es
el enfermo de Europa uno de los pocos
países que es ahora más pobre que hace
20 años y diréis por qué tenemos un par
de vídeos donde lo explicamos en
detalles uno de visualpolitik y otro de
visual económico os dejo el enlace en la
descripción pero os hago un breve
resumen Italia arrastra problemas
sistémicos que hacen que sea casi
imposible que funcione tiene un estado
enorme y totalmente ineficiente con más
de 3 millones de funcionarios y
muchísimo gasto público pero eso no es
todo una de las grandes debilidades de
Italia es la burocracia más Absurda que
os podáis imaginar por ejemplo casi
todas las profesiones están colegiadas Y
eso significa que si quieres trabajar
como periodista o informático necesitas
una licencia y conseguir esa licencia es
un proceso que directamente parece de
otra época como curiosidad te contaré
que aquí en visualpolitik estuvimos
trabajando durante un tiempo con un
italiana quería conseguir la licencia de
periodista para poder trabajar en medios
clásicos como y correr de la cera o la
república Y para eso tenía que demostrar
experiencia en medios pero por lo visto
trabajar en un canal de YouTube no es
experiencia en medios porque según la
burocracia Italiana un canal de YouTube
con millones de Seguidores Que emiten
varios idiomas no cuenta como un medio
de comunicación por qué Porque patatas
Pues bien pesa todos estos problemas la
Italia de los años 80 crecía gracias a
una cosa eran adictos a la devaluación
Italia devaluaba su divisa
sistemáticamente para que sus productos
fueran más baratos en el mercado
internacional Durante los años 80 y 90
el Made In Italia arrasaba en Europa
problema en la década de los 2000 china
entró en la Organización Mundial del
Comercio e Italia entró en el euro
conclusión no podían competir con los
precios aún más baratos de las empresas
chinas y tampoco podían seguir
devaluándose divisa conclusión una larga
crisis de la que aún no han salido
[Música]
en este momento Italia es El séptimo
país del mundo endeuda en relación con
el pib y el quinto en deuda per cápita y
de hecho hoy en día Italia es uno de los
mayores dolores de cabeza de toda Europa
y en cierto modo buena parte de todo
esto se debe a lo que hizo o más bien no
hizo Silvio verlos Connie Pese a que
tuvo más poder que casi ningún otro
político
y diréis Y qué ha hecho ver los Connie
los últimos años pues lo cierto Es que
nunca ha abandonado la política sin
embargo
apenas podemos destacar ninguna posición
política relevante salvo ésta Silvio
berlusconi el ex Primer Ministro
defiende la guerra rusa las puertas de
las elecciones italianas Exacto
berlusconi ha estado apoyando a Rusia en
la Guerra de Ucrania y diréis por qué
puso argumentación se basa en que conoce
personalmente a Vladimir Putin y son muy
buenos amigos y en este caso Parece que
la vida Privada de berlusconi sí afecta
a sus posiciones políticas O al menos
eso es lo que se desprende de fotos como
esta conclusión final nadie puede negar
que verlos Connie fue un auténtico genio
un hombre hecho a sí mismo consiguió
tener más poder que casi ningún otro ser
humano en la historia juntó en una misma
persona el poder mediático político y
económico sin embargo utilizó todo ese
poder de una forma cuanto menos mediocre
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
llegaremos a ver a un nuevo líder que
aglutine tanto poder como brusconi en
Italia o en otro país y lo más
importante os gustaría llegar a los
ochenta y tantos años con tantísima
energía como si lvio podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
recordad con el código politik acabado
en K podéis disfrutar de tres meses
extra totalmente gratis con surfshark el
link como siempre en la descripción y
como decimos en todos los vídeos no
olvidéis que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]